now we're going to talk about arthritis
tonight we're going to be talking about
a lot of different things relative to
bone and joints right but this is
encapsulated best with the term
arthritis which everybody has heard it
may interest you to know that arthritis
is a perfect example of fancy-schmancy
Latin doctor talk designed to make you
the patient feel intellectually inferior
our thright as' is Latin for
inflammation in the joint right so what
do you do you've got inflammation in
your joints you know that you've got
inflammation in your joints you know
that you've got pain in the joints you
run to the md's office because it's the
only medicine that's legally allowed to
be practiced in your state that your
medical insurance pays for it it's the
only medicine they've taught you about
it's the only medicine you know anything
about and the MD does 3,000 dollars of
diagnostic discovery and tells you that
you have arthritis which is Latin for
inflammation of the joint you already
knew that before you went into their
office and then they're more than happy
to give you medications the intention of
which is not to cure the arthritis the
intention of which is to manage your
symptoms now I'm often criticized for
being too harsh on the MDS and for
having MD bashing sessions and that's
not what this is at all this is about
perspective gaining perspective on the
delivery of medicine all around the
world so that you can understand whom
you should bring your body to for the
best possible outcome we don't have this
type of education this type of knowledge
this type of understanding because for
the last 100 years all that we've known
about is MD directed medicine MD
directed medicine MD directed medicine
MD directed medicine so drugs and
surgery are wonderful when they're
applied efficiently and effective
and in fact that is the domain of the MD
the MD is best trained for a surgery
when it's absolutely necessary
a handful of infectious diseases and
trauma care but when we let the MDS
start to get their hands on in our
threaded condition or a bone in a joint
condition it's bad
you know facts are a stubborn thing
while we have given ourselves over
exclusively to the care of the MDS in
the United States 46 million adults have
some form of arthritis by 2030 that's 16
years from now 67 million Americans aged
18 18 or older I bet you thought
arthritis was a geriatric illness not so
much by 2030 67 million Americans are
projected to have some type of arthritis
two-thirds here's a startling statistic
two-thirds of the people that have
arthritis are under the age of 65 now
this is an interesting pitch this is an
interesting pitch you'll read this all
the time by the way front page of USA
Today front page of The Wall Street
Journal front page of the New York Times
right
in 2003 arthritis costs the US economy
128 billion well that's correct
but if it's costing somebody something
somebody else is profiting something so
you never read the headline orthopedic
doctors made a killing this year they
profited 128 billion dollars on the
backs of your suffering it's good to be
an orthopedic doctor
you never hear it pitch to you that way
but that is in fact a fact while we have
given ourselves over to exclusive
disease management by the allopathic Lee
trained MD
the arthritic statistics have not budged
actually more and more and more people
are getting arthritis now if this were a
genetic illness then didn't gregor
mendel didn't Charles Darwin argue for
the survival of the fittest if our
thright us was genetic as the MDS will
tell you that it is wouldn't a rational
person make the assumption that there
should be less and less and less and
less of it every generation because
aren't the weak genes supposed to be
deselected from the herd arthritis is
not genetic and anybody that's told you
arthritis says genetic roots if they're
a medical professional should have their
medical license revoked it's the second
most frequently reported chronic
condition in the United States and this
I'm assuming is not any different in any
other industrialized nation now the MDS
are trained to believe that your body
does not have the ability to fix itself
that once you're sick you're screwed and
your only option is to let the MD manage
your symptoms with drugs until they get
so bad that you need surgery this is the
philosophical orientation which informs
all of the MDS treatments I mean think
about heartburn does your medical doctor
not know how to cure heartburn no they
know how to manage heartburn with the
little purple pill but they can't cure
it nor can they cure any chronic disease
it's not the job of the MD to cure it
nor is it the job of the MD to
understand what's causing the illness
it's the job of the MD to manage your
symptoms with drugs until it's so bad
that you need an operation bad for you
good for them this data just released
two days ago by Medicare
by Medicare in the United States they
listed the salaries of all of the
different physicians in the United
States the money that they pay different
physicians in the United States at the
top of the food chain orthopedic
surgeons the annual salary in the United
States if you're an orthopedic doctor
doing knee replacement joint replacement
surgery 475 it's half a million bucks
it's good to be a joint repair
specialist good for their pocketbook not
so good for you
because interestingly enough statistics
are a stubborn thing now there are many
different types of arthritis now
remember the MDS are excellent at naming
and categorizing things but they're
horrible at figuring out how to fix them
so over the last hundred years they have
categorized many different types of the
arthritic condition there's rheumatoid
arthritis where they tell you your
body's develop antibodies against itself
which is nonsense they'll tell you
there's psoriatic arthritis there's
traumatic arthritis there's degenerative
osteoarthritis etc etc etc and they're
correct you can categorize and sub
categorize and delineate and draw
parameters around this presentation of
the illness and this presentation of the
illness ad infinitum but keep in mind
your MD may be the nicest human being
ever walked God's green earth but by
virtue of their training by virtue of
their philosophical orientation about
the relationship between the human body
and disease they have no earthly idea
what so ever about what causes arthritis
none whatsoever it's not their thing to
understand that it's their thing to
deliver drugs to manage the symptom now
look I can prescribe drugs I'm not
against drugs thank God for a novocaine
thank God for morphine thank God for
penicillin it's not the drug it's how
it's used it's not the gun it's how it's
used the way that md's use drugs it's
the leading cause of death in the United
States so when you present your body to
md within any type of a bone or joint
issue the MDS treatment protocol is this
they'll give you anti-inflammatory meds
and payment then they'll give you
surgery then they'll give you more pain
meds then they'll give you more
anti-inflammatory meds and then they
give you more surgery I've had patients
that have had four different knee
operations on the same knee now we must
not overlook the obvious all you have to
do is follow the money
128 billion dollars a year is given to
the MDS who treat arthritis but they
don't have any intention know how
knowledge or understanding of how to
cure it it's good to be an orthopedic
surgeon like the fella said when all you
have is a hammer everything looks like a
nail when all you have is an axe all you
want to do is cut things down we need
perspective ladies and gentlemen because
we do not have any and we are up against
it and we are up against it hard
the statistics are startling the
arthritic condition is getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse and
it starts in the teenage years
and if we don't do something about it
well that's why we're here to do
something about it
by the way with my md colleagues cousins
it's all about research and double
blindness and double blind that and
let's prove it with some type of
double-blinded placebo-controlled
clinical study right well that's only
good as long as it doesn't go against
the grain according to the Journal of
the American Medical Association in July
2002 that's 12 years ago knee
replacement surgery for osteoarthritis
doesn't work this was published in the
Journal of the American Medical
Association doesn't work it's a
temporary fix at best
now if you don't believe me just ask
yourself how many people do you know
that have a prosthetic knee a prosthetic
hip a prosthetic elbow a prosthetic
shoulder who feel great three years four
years after the surgery how are they
doing not that great because the joint
replacement does not fix the cause of
the illness period joint replacement for
most types of arthritis is like painting
over the mold in the basement without
addressing the cause of the mold well
you can't see it anymore can't smell it
anymore good job boys let's go home and
buy a Porsche only a matter of time
until there's more mold last time I
looked that was called quackery
promoting expensive medical treatments
that do not work by the way this doctor
is
performing a cat scan now here's what we
need to talk about we're going to leave
all the doom and gloom behind now we're
going to get into the meat and potatoes
of the holistic wisdom concerning the
pathogenesis of bone and joint trouble
and what to do to support and promote
your body's ability to fix itself
nutrify the joints feed the body the
nutrition that the joints need to
maintain their structural integrity
there's a good idea
remove inflammatory agents from the diet
most if not all inflammatory agents that
enter the body enter through your food
and drink which is scientific jargon for
your eating stuff that's causing
inflammation and you don't even know it
you need to stop it I mean if you had a
little fire going in your backyard right
you know your you had a barbecue and you
dumped the coals over and now you're
trying to put the coals out would you do
that with gasoline gasoline makes the
fire worse
well there are 10 foods which we're
going to talk about later 10 foods which
if you eat them cause inflammation and
if you have any type of an itis anywhere
in your body even if it's not arthritis
any type of an itis the consumption of
these foods will promote inflammation
it's like rubbing salt into a wound and
it's not a good idea
our therapeutics are designed to support
and promote the body's ability to fix
itself why because there's no simpler
way to put it
arthritis is a nutritional deficiency
disease you don't have arthritis because
you have a bad gene you don't have
arthritis because you have voodoo curse
you don't have arthritis because
of the aging process you have a bad
joint because you have a bad doctor it's
that simple
25 million dollars of federally funded
research done by my mentor colleague and
friend dr. Joel Wallach the founder of
the youngevity company proved that there
are 90 essential nutrients that the
human body needs in order to function
the way that God intended it to 90
essential nutrients here's the breakdown
16 minerals 16 vitamins 12 amino acids
and 2 essential fatty acids for a grand
total of 90 nutrients and if you hang
out with us long enough you will see
this slogan everywhere it's directly
underneath me 90 for life that's what
this refers to the 90 essential
nutrients that are necessary for life by
the way a nutrient is considered
essential if the body needs it but can't
make it cholesterol is very very very
important for your health that's right I
said important that's a whole other
webinar there's no such thing as high
cholesterol for all intents and purposes
cholesterol is your friend but it's not
an essential nutrient because the body
can make it
cholesterol is so important to your
health your body makes it the 90
essential nutrients are necessary for
health but your body can't make them so
they must be imported into the body
every day they must go down the hatch
every day the only problem is and it's a
big problem it is an overlooked problem
this is a billion pound gorilla in the
middle of the country that nobody sees
it is impossible to get all 90 essential
news
from food you can't do it it's not just
tricky it's not just challenging it's
impossible and here is why 90 essential
nutrients the lion's share are minerals
66% 2/3 of your nutrient needs are
minerals
things like calcium and magnesium sulfur
zinc selenium the only problem with
minerals is the only person that can
make them an earl is God plants can't
make minerals animals can't make
minerals if a plant could make a mineral
we could bioengineer carrots to make
gold and we'd all be rich minerals are
found in the soil or not here's a map of
a very important mineral for human
health selenium in the US now on this
map the legend you know the pinkish and
reddish colors it's a lot of selenium
their yellowish you get not so much
bluish not so much gray forget it and if
there's white there is no selenium at
all now remember this is just one
mineral out of 60 there are 60 other
maps but they're all different there is
no place on the planet that we've
discovered in the topsoil where all
sixty minerals are found it doesn't
exist it does not exist so the only way
selenium or calcium or zinc or sulfur
gets into your body is if the roots of
the plant that you're eating touched it
when they were growing same goes for
cow's milk if a cows eating grass that
was grown in soil that was calcium
deficient the cow's milk is calcium
deficient interestingly enough ounce for
ounce there's more calcium and maple
syrup than there is in cow's milk
who know we knew
and that's why we do these webinars
everybody needs to know this and nobody
does now
this isn't rocket science if this tank
this drawing represents your body's
nutritional needs right in order for
your body to be healthy and for
everything to work the way that nature
and God intended it to your nutritional
tank needs to be topped off every day
with the 90 essential nutrient
every day but because nobody knows this
nobody supplements appropriately and
even if you have a perfect diet you eat
exactly the right stuff that you need to
when it's all organic you can secure
about 30 40 % of your body's nutrient
needs from food but then you experience
the stress of life emotional stress
financial stress environmental stress
crap in the air crap in the food crap in
the water bugs viruses germs lions and
tigers and bears oh my guess what the
stress does it burns right through your
reserves now you're running on fumes
baby you know what happens when you run
on fumes things start to break why you
think you got osteoporosis which is
thinning of the bones because you have a
bad gene no you got osteoporosis because
for the last 30 years your body has been
deficient in the stuff it needs to keep
the bones healthy and every day
unwittingly you're eating food that's
causing chronic low-grade inflammation
to the joints because you listen to dr.
oz tell you what to eat dr. oz is a
cardiac surgeon you want to get dr oz's
advice you should listen to him about
what type of chess
to use and what type of scalpel and
which type of stitch is the best to
close the chest cavity after the
operation
but we've been socialized by a hundred
years of pharmaceutical profiteering
propaganda to think that the MD has a
secret decoder ring to all things
medical just by virtue of their
education and they do not your medical
doctor bless his heart or her heart
maybe the nicest human being in the
world but they have no education no
appreciation no respect and no
understanding whatsoever about the
relationship between medical nutrition
and your health and that oversight is
killing you a leading cause of death in
the United States is MD directed medical
therapeutics seven hundred eighty
thousand people a year are killed by md
treatments that's more people that are
killed by heart disease or cancer
leading cause of bankruptcy in the
United States and these therapeutics
because the most expensive therapeutic
is the one that doesn't work so you
don't have osteoporosis because you have
a voodoo curse you have osteoporosis
because your body ran out of the stuff
it needed to keep the bones healthy so
this is a cross-section of your spine
and the white stuff in this drawing is
the bones your backbones the stuff the
chiropractor's adjusts we love
chiropractors by the way the red tissue
here is the cartilage cushion between
the joints between the bones and the
black green and purple stuff is the
nerves okay now when you're healthy the
red colored discs they're not really red
in life but for artistic expression
right there red though those disks are
like feather pillows and they're child
full of feathers but as you go down the
road of life if you're not consuming the
right nutrients the bones and the discs
run out of structural integrity because
you've stopped feeding them so what's
going to happen when the disc loses its
structural integrity the weight of your
body is going to make it squish it's
going to flatten out like a pancake and
then it's going to touch the nerve that
it should be protecting you know what
that translates to out pain baby and
then some more pain but the MDS have no
earthly understanding about what causes
this and all they have for this is
anti-inflammatories pain meds
anti-inflammatories pain meds and don't
dare go to those chiropractor you got to
be kidding me
once again I cannot stress enough we do
not have a free medical market in the
free world we do not access to medical
information has been monopolized by the
pharmaceutical industry for the last
hundred years you know you've got
garden-variety arthritis right it hurts
man why do you have garden-variety
arthritis because your body's run out of
this stuff it needs to maintain a
healthy joint your skeleton is begging
you for nutrients but you don't know
what you don't know and when it comes to
your bones and joints
it is a slow steady slide into the land
of pain and suffering which the MDS
our only too happy to address with
expensive dangerous side-effect ridden
treatments which have been proven and
published to not work and yet they roll
them out and walk away with half a
million dollars a year sleep very
soundly while you're still in pain and
this passes for the best medical system
in the world you've got to be kidding me
well you know it's like the movie The
Matrix
you know everybody's wrong well you know
what I'm the red pill it's time to wake
up so I cannot emphasize enough in the
context of my private practice in states
in which I'm licensed and regulated as a
physician I can treat disease in the
context of my youngevity business in the
context of my relationship with my
youngevity distributors in the context
of this webinar and most of the public
webinars that I do all of the webinars
for dr. Glidden insiders we do not treat
disease but what we do do is recommend
therapeutics science-based clinically
verified formulated and delivered by
licensed physicians the intention of
which are to support and promote your
bone your bones and your joints ability
to fix themselves in this case and
that's what we're going to talk about
next how do we support and promote your
body's ability to have health
the bones and joints it's easier than
falling off a potato truck so let's
break it down the cartilage of your
joints are made from glucosamine sulfate
chondroitin sulfate and a funny little
thing called hyaluronic acid say that
three times fast so guess what we do if
I've got weak ligaments tendons bones or
joints I'm gonna recommend supplements
that are filled with glucosamine sulfate
chondroitin sulfate and hyaluronic acid
hallelujah and past the Hat this is it
it's gluco job that's why it was
developed now look we don't really have
enough time to get into the the the
science behind this right but the fact
of the matter is not all nutritional
supplements are created equal
nutritional supplements are like wine
all why is made from grapes there's a
great deal of difference between Annie
Boone Springs green apple wine and a
nice California Pinot well what's the
difference the recipe I've been doing
nature Pathak medical therapeutics for a
quarter of a century my profession
members of my profession are the
stewards of medical nutrition this is
our thing this is our wheelhouse and as
God is my witness I am here to tell you
that in 25 years of clinical work dr.
Wallach snue trishal supplements like
this one gluco gel and this one which is
a liquid glucose L are more effective
than anything I've ever used and by the
way I used to work for a nutritional
supplement company that only sold two
physicians I've been around this block a
lot
what it boils down to is science recipe
and clinical effectiveness youngevity on
all three of those counts has a lock
this stuff was formulated from 25
million dollars of federally funded
research 26,000 autopsies and ten
million blood chemistry's and histo
pathologies
done by the founder of youngevity dr.
Joel Wallach it doesn't get any better
than this
but the only way that you're going to
have any understanding that I'm not
blowing smoke is the try it and see for
yourself because the proof of this
puddin is definitely in the eatin now
you want to have a car that lasts for
200,000 miles you're going to change the
oil you're going to put transmission
fluid in it you got to put brake fluid
in it you got to put power steering
fluid in it you're going to top
everything off right for goodness sake
we take most of us take better care of
our cars than we do of our bodies but
not because we're slackers just because
we don't know any better because
nobody's ever taught us nobody's ever
lined it up like this surgery is
complicated healing is easy because your
body knows how to fix itself your body
wants to fix itself so I have the
easiest job in the world a deliver unto
your body this stuff it needs to fix
itself
stop eating stuff that's gumming up the
works and get out of the way this is the
recipe to optimize joint function period
end of discussion and I don't care if
you have rheumatoid arthritis
osteoarthritis it doesn't matter which
subset of bone and joint trouble you
have it does not matter what the MDS
have called it this is what we recommend
you do now the last thing on this list
killer biotic we only recommend if the
diagnosis is rheumatoid arthritis
because we believe that rheumatoid
arthritis is nutrient deficiencies on
top of a parasitic infection of the
joint capsule by a little bug called a
mycoplasma if you have rheumatoid
arthritis we believe that there is a bug
living in the joint capsule that's
messing things up so we support the
immune system and hope that by doing so
the immune system will rally and kill
the bug while we're delivering medical
nutrition so for every single bone and
joint issue we use beyond tangy
tangerine liquid calcium which is osteo
FX gluco gel and the capsules or the
liquid or both essential fatty acids
plant derived minerals for everything
for every different delineation of bone
and joint trouble known to humankind now
or in the future and if there's a
rheumatic a rheumatoid problem we add
killer biotic and it's that simple now
one of the secrets to our success is not
only the recipes but the dosage now
does a tank need more oil than a
Volkswagen yeah yes it does
does somebody who's 300 pounds need more
glucosamine sulfate and more calcium and
more vitamin A than somebody who's 95
pounds yes they do
so we have developed foundation medical
nutrition boilerplate health recovery
protocols which are dosed in a perfect
world based on your weight that's why
these delineations are like this now you
don't need to worry about doing all the
math or if you're a guest
if somebody's brought you here tonight
and the information that I've given you
has piqued your curiosity and you want
to get started they know how many
bottles a month you meet based upon your
body weight because it's easy math we've
got it all figured out
but the point that I want to make here
right now is one of the reasons that we
get such unbelievably remarkable success
here is because we're the only ones in
the world that dose medical nutrition
health recovery strategies based upon
your body weight it's a very important
distinction here's what the stuff looks
like by the way that's a healthy bone
and joint pack plant two rock minerals
and killer biotic you already saw with
the liquid leuco gel looks like that's
it
you've got unhealthy bones and joints
guess what this is the secret sauce to
strengthen and support and promote your
body's ability to have healthy bones and
joints and if you've been suffering
within our threaded condition if you've
been suffering with osteoporosis or any
type of a bone in a joint problem from
more than three months most people are
suffering with this stuff for years
they've gotten use to it after you take
this and you clean your diet up and your
health improves you're gonna be filled
with righteous indignation about the
last months lost years that you've had
because your MDS sold you a
cock-and-bull story the proof of the
pudding is in the eating ladies and
gentlemen and my people are destroyed by
lack of knowledge feed your body feed it
give your body the nutrition that it
needs to have healthy bones and joints
stop eating food that's gumming up the
works get out of the way now some people
because of religious reasons can't do
the gluco gel because our gluco gel is
derived from shellfish so if for
whatever reasons you can't eat animal
products then as a workaround for gluco
gel we've got these two products z
radical and few coid z z radical is a
liquid few coins e as a capsule both of
these supplements contain a sea
vegetable extract called few coid n' and
there are over 1000 published studies on
the positive effects of few coid one of
which is the stimulation of stem cell
production so if you still have stem
cells in your joint which you do and you
take few corden in sufficient amounts
chances are very good that your body
will be stimulated to generate new
cartilage tissue and if anybody tells
you that that's impossible they're lying
to you
we do it all of the time now we're
holistic which means we don't just slap
and dab we don't just medicate symptoms
we don't just sweep things under the rug
it's a two-step program step number one
nutrify your body fill up your tank
appropriate for your body weight with
the right stuff in the right recipes
step number two
stop swallowing stuff that's hurting
your body now I have done hour-long
webinars just on this slide right here
don't have time to do that tonight
there's a video a free video on YouTube
circulating on YouTube called against
the grain which explains why wheat
barley rye and oats are like death on a
plate after this webinar just go to
youtube and do dr. Glidden against the
grain and you can pull it up and watch
it and it will explain why the gluten in
wheat barley rye oats is one of the
worst foods for the human body
long story short wheat barley rye in
oats harm the small intestine and the
small intestine is the structure in the
body the organ in the body whose job is
to absorb nutrition into the bloodstream
it's not a good idea to damage that but
every time you eat a whole wheat
sandwich or pasta you're damaging your
small intestinal tract
who knew by the way who told you to eat
that stuff Monsanto General Mills
Betty Crocker who wasn't even a real
person stop it
bad dog no biscuit oil in a bottle is
also one of the worst foods a human
being can consume oil in a bottle is
loaded with free radicals free radicals
promote inflammation in the body period
if you heat an oil the free radical
production goes ballistic I don't even
want you to be downwind of fried food
that's how bad it is well done red meat
contains a carcinogenic substance called
a heterocyclic amine and it will hurt
you it's not present as much in rare red
meat or meat that's stewed or put in
soups or in a crock-pot so you want to
have a steak I just had one last night
by the way have it rare or medium rare
no grill marks because all that charred
meat is heterocyclic amines and that
crap will kill you
nitrates added as preservatives to bacon
salami sausage Turkey deli ham converts
into a carcinogenic substance called the
nitrosamine which causes cancer not a
good idea now you want to have bacon
sausage ham pepperoni no problemo just
make sure it doesn't have nitrates in it
period the skins of baked potatoes yams
and sweet potatoes how about that
the crunchy skins you know when it's
really yummy that's also loaded with
heterocyclic amines it's death on a
plate you want to boil a potato a yam or
sweet potato be my guest you can eat as
much of that as you want because it's
only the baking process that makes the
chemical convert
into a heterocyclic a me a carbonated
drink drunk with a meal neutralizes
stomach acid
the little fizzy bubbles its carbon
dioxide carbon dioxide neutralizes
stomach acid when you are healthy your
stomach acid is so strong that if you
chopped your finger off and swallowed it
your stomach would digest it down to the
bone your body wants and needs to have
strong stomach acid but when you wash
down lunch or dinner with a Coke or a
Perrier or a beer or anything that's got
bubbles in it
you're inhibiting digestion and you're
gonna die sucka but you're gonna die
slowly so you want to have a carbonated
drink ever between meals not with a meal
now just in this one slide assuming of
course I'm correct which I am the
information on this one slide will save
your life and inquiring minds want to
know
why don't you know this because we don't
have a free medical market because your
medical doctor may be the nicest human
being in the world but they have no
training no respect no appreciation and
no understanding of medical nutrition
zero you know what we're like we're like
the people years ago that said hey
everybody it's a good idea to purify the
water not to pee upstream and drink
downstream and by the way we have to
have a good public sanitation deal going
on we need clean water and we need a way
to eliminate our waste so it doesn't
hurt
just by doing those two things
historically human life expectancy
double well the information that I'm
talking about tonight the information
that dr. Wallach has been talking about
for 20 years the information that
youngevity Nation champions every day
has this potential I mean think about
everybody all of the time is eating food
that's hurting them all of the time and
everybody's nutritional tank is running
on fumes
so something breaks and you go to the
allopathic MD who doesn't believe your
body can fix itself and what do they do
they throw a drug at it and so we die
slowly well guess what there's a new
sheriff in town
there's a new way and it's our way now
because nobody knows this and everybody
needs to dr. Wallach set youngevity up
on purpose as a network marketing
company on purpose in order to grow and
populate a grassroots coalition so I
tell you you tell somebody they tell
somebody they tell somebody yada yada
yada that's how it goes worked pretty
good for the church by the way started
with two guys look at it now all
word-of-mouth there are two ways you can
interface with youngevity you can
interface with us as a customer you can
tell us what your complaints aren't
we'll tell you what we recommend to
support and promote the structure and
function of that part of your body and
we'll sell you the stuff at the
wholesale price
not bad now if you're feeling a little
deficient in vitamin M if there's more
rent left at the end of the month then
there is money if you need a little
financial salvation and we can help you
can join youngevity as a business
builder and as a business builder as a
member of youngevity we will pay you
handsomely to promote our message of
health recovery through science-based
clinically verified medical nutrition
and that beats a poke in the eye with a
sharp stick because what are you doing
you're helping people to have a better
quality of life with science-based
clinically verified pragmatic and
effective treatments that actually work
now people don't like it when I do this
but I'm gonna do it anyway remember it's
all about the numbers
46 million people in North America with
arthritis if you were able to reach one
tenth of one percent of those people one
tenth of one percent of those people
that's four thousand six hundred people
so you you get into youngevity you give
us $10 as a membership fee
ten bucks one-time only we show you how
to show this message to people in a way
that attracts them to you we show you
how to be a good youngevity network
marketer we teach you how to be an
upstanding member of the community we
teach you to be someone whom your
neighbors will come to love and respect
and you show what we're up to to any and
all
and then you've got other people who
want to help you and build the business
and they show it to any and all and
after a couple of years of doing this
your organization has reached 4,600
people with arthritis one-tenth of one
percent you've joined youngevity for ten
bucks the average healthy side pack for
a bone and joint health recovery is
about two hundred and fifty bucks as a
young japanese member you secure about
eight percent of that every month every
time somebody buys you know what that
translates to ninety thousand dollars a
month now look would ninety thousand
dollars a month make a difference to you
would that make a difference in your
lifestyle and would you sleep better at
night knowing that you were able to make
that much money by helping people not by
cheating people by actually helping
people to have a better quality of life
would you sleep soundly that night now
look this is an extreme example right
which is why everybody hates it when I
do it but I don't care because I'm
playing a big game here I'm playing a
big game there was somebody at Timmy
Hortons yesterday there was somebody at
Starbucks
there was somebody pumping gas right
next to you last week who went to bed
the night before praying to God for help
because conventional medicine has led us
down they've led us down hard and people
don't know what to do if you help us
spread our message there is no limit to
how many people you can help
and remember armies need to be paid
right well guess what
this is a non militant grassroots
coalition of the informed people who've
taken it upon themselves taken upon
themselves to business of humanity you
don't know what you're missing ladies
and gentlemen youngevity is here for the
long haul if you're a guest get with the
person that invited you here tonight see
how it is you can work with us you work
with us as a customer fantastic give
this stuff a try
clean your diet up nutrify your body
take back your health if you need a
little extra cash you know a couple of
hundred bucks a month
great thousand bucks a month - great
we'll show you how to do it we're on a
mission to help lifts people up and in
this business arising tide lifts all
boats
ladies and gentlemen I'm dr. Peter
Glidden thanks again for your time
especially if you're a guest here I
really do appreciate it cuz you didn't
know me from Adam right you trusted the
person who brought you here I hope I
haven't disappointed if you like what
I'm talking about
in tonight's webinar I have a radio show
Monday through Friday you can listen to
it all around the world on the internet
from three to five central get with the
person that invited you here tonight and
see how it is you can work with us I
look forward to meeting you in person at
some time in the future and until I do I
will remain your steadfast advocate for
health dr. Peter Glidden hoping that you
live long and prosper see all around
campus thanks again